hey guys it is the 26th of September my
name's Jess and you're watching game
[ __ ] news first up today titanfall 2
developer respawned has addressed
whether the game will be getting a
higher framerate on PC
during a recent Q&A the developer were
asked if they would consider increasing
the framerate limit above the 144 frames
per second cap on PC producer Dru McCoy
replied we can investigate slightly
higher frame rates but in initial
testing we ran into some issues with
incredibly high frame rates he also
reiterated the titanfall 2 will not
support PC and console cross-play
explaining as much as I personally think
cross-platform play would be awesome it
unfortunately will not be in the game at
this time elsewhere in the QA was
revealed that the game will include an
effects detail slider and the ability to
disable depth of field when aiming in
multiplayer on both PC and console
titanfall 2 is out on October 28th for
ps4 Xbox one and PC according to a
developer only post shared on neogaf the
steam store may be undergoing an
overhaul the blog post indicates that
Valve will refresh the homepage and
introduce a prominent popular among
front section so you can hop on that
bandwagon valve may also be introducing
more steam curator options as the post
suggests the curator program could be
improved
curators will apparently be able to
indicate whether their post is meant to
be seen as a recommendation lack thereof
or whether it is only informational
other reported changes include a new
features section showcasing new releases
that have cracked the top seller list
and a new left-hand column to include
links to new releases top sellers
recently updated titles and upcoming
releases the update will apparently
start rolling out in a few weeks
finally former CEO of Sony Computer
Entertainment America Jack Tretton has
said that the PlayStation Vita came out
too late
Tretton told IGN now that I don't work
there anymore
I think internally it was this is a
great machine it's just too late the
world has shifted to portable devices
that aren't dedicated game
machines Trenton said that in comparison
the PSP was a bigger hit while the Vita
was a nice machine that came out at a
time when very few people needed a
dedicated portable device the PS Vita
has sold more than five million units in
Japan as of June 2016 while we don't
have up-to-date sales figures for the
console globally it's safe to say
Nintendo's 3ds is likely well ahead
being that almost 16 million units have
been sold globally as of June this year
that is everything from me today do let
me know your thoughts on today's stories
head to GameSpot for news on battlefield
one and the division and I will see you
again tomorrow